we are here in Indianapolis site of the
Scouting Combine home of the Colts and
the head coach of the local NFL team
joins us now entering year three in that
weird D thank you it's gotta be just a
blur for you right you waited so long to
get that job but here comes year three
for Frank Reich great to see you and
welcome back to the center thanks might
get it it is a blur but that's life in
the NFL right I mean it's all good
and it's exciting this time of year
getting back in the groove and it seems
like so much of the job is about dealing
with the unexpected dealing with
adversity and no one dealt with more
than you last year to find out a week
and a half before the start of the
season your starting quarterback isn't
gonna be playing for you anymore and you
got to come up with a plan B right away
and you handle it as well as anyone ever
could well I appreciate that I mean yeah
was a shock to all of us but it that's
life I mean there's and it's just
amplified because of the spotlight that
we're in and the type of player that
Andrew was so I thought we did handle it
very well that was a credit to our
players you know the locker room to be
able to handle that particularly a
credit to Jacoby for how he handled
Jim Irsay the owner of the team had a
press conference on Sunday and he was
talking for a bit about Andrew Luck and
it was kind of vague as to whether he
thought there's a chance Andrew Luck
could come walking back through the door
do you have any sense that he's going to
after a year away or maybe after two
years away decide you know what I'm
ready to do this again yeah I really
know as far as I my mind is you know
he's a friend I talk to him occasionally
we communicate I sense none of that we
don't talk about that I think he's
retired I think I think it's normal
course of business as we go and I don't
think there's any other way to approach
it when you talk to him do you listen
for any clues like you know like oh yeah
gee I really I really miss being at my
locker I really miss I miss Saturday's
before getting anything he said that
made you think that you never know how
the world is gonna play out you know
he's like he's like any other X player
there are any X player there's all
you're always gonna miss your buddies in
the locker room that's normal so I don't
read into that the clue that hey he
wants to come back he's just a good
friend and like hanging out with them
occasionally we're all busy so
yeah I'm not reading any anything into
those comments did you sense that it was
coming no one else did did you have an
inkling and when did you have the
inkling that it may head this way for
Andrew Luck I really didn't I mean I
didn't know until like everybody we I
knew a couple days before everybody else
a week before no inkling I think
everybody knows that andrew is a unique
guy and was wired is wired a little bit
different it's part of what makes him
the the player that he is so in essence
if this was gonna happen to someone it
would happen with someone of his
personality who he's a team guy the
group law and all that stuff we all know
that that wasn't the most important
thing to him so in that respect not a
surprise but in the moment a big
surprise jacobee percent comes in leads
a team to a five and two record they had
the knee injury against the Steelers
missed a little time felt like he was
never quite the same after that when
I've detected in the aftermath of the
season and this is kind of an
organizational vibe it's almost
ambivalence now you haven't been
ambivalent but Chris Ballard's comments
Jay Mercy's comments like where do you
stand right now which eco Bieber set his
role as your starter and this question
of whether or not when free agency rolls
around or the draft rolls around there's
gonna be another quarterback potentially
take over the job yeah I mean yeah
there's nothing as you said there's
nothing to be ambivalent about he's our
God and in this league it's not many
guys had the luxury of saying hey I've
job security locked I don't have to ever
worry about any competition that's just
not real life in the NFL so Jacoby
Jacoby understands that he knows he has
to earn everything and he and he does
and so you know we'll take it a day at a
time
Chris and I talking all the time how do
we make this team better every position
gets evaluated every player gets
evaluated Jim Irsay said the other day
all options are on the table how
involved will you be as coach of the
team in evaluating the options with
Chris Ballard and making a decision on
whether or not there's a free agent
who's pursued whether or not there's a
guy that you try to trade for whether or
not there's a guy that you target in the
draft how much of that question are you
involved in resolving yeah every aspect
of every decision at every level wearing
it out till it can't be wore out
and especially like mr. say said the
other day when it comes to the
quarterback position if there is if
we're there ever goes if there's a road
that ever gets traveled down that's a
road that will be mr. sa Chris and
myself no free agency's been around in
its current form since 1993-94 and I
can't remember a year where there were
this many like quarterbacks never
removed like okay yeah there's free ages
but that applies everybody but
quarterbacks quarterbacks stay put
I've never seen a year like this with so
many guys who are available or could be
available via trade release or whatever
yeah and that's exciting for the league
I mean it's exciting for media fans you
know how's this all going to play out
not every guys the right fit for every
team but you know every club will do the
same thing that we're doing evaluate
what's the right fit how does it fit
into the long-term plans because one
thing here with the Colts is you know
when Chris and I and mr. Tsai sit down
and talk there there's a very distinct
way we're building and and mr. Tsai is
incredibly supportive and has a you know
we'll spend the money but we want to
build through the draft we want to build
inside out we want to Reese on our own
guys and then be very selective about
those guys we pursue you know I'd never
thought about this angle coach but at
some point the dust is going to settle
on this quarterback carousel and you're
gonna be looking at your schedule and
you're gonna have some teams with new
quarterbacks and all of a sudden like
you know guys been in the system for 20
years and here he is with this new coach
new says and you're not going to know
how to plan for those games and I don't
know how many I mean we've you know we
don't know until the schedule comes out
and how this all resolves but you can
have a bunch of games that have a much
different complexion because if a
quarterback change it was made yeah
you're right because the quarterback is
such a central cog to the offensive
wheels so that's something you adapt to
as you go now a lot of these guys have a
track record of what they do and what
they like to do so you factor all that
into it you know it looks like we're
heading towards 17 regular season games
any thoughts on you know you you you you
were a player you've seen the wear and
tear you see the wear and tear on your
guys now do you think your guys can suit
up for another regular-season game with
the promise of both season ideally can
they put in that extra regular-season
game and still you know be okay overall
you know I mean I certainly I certainly
understand whether you know the players
perspective and the the wear and tear of
the season but you know I think today
players more than so than ever do a
great job of taking care of themselves I
honestly don't delve into that CBA issue
very far right I mean that's out of my
control we've all given our two cents
where we've been asked to give our two
cents I trust the decisions that are
made
they tell us seventeen I'm we're good to
go and we'll adjust accordingly I've
heard from a couple other coaches hey
we're talking about players get another
game check for 17 games a week another
game check - that's funny no comment no
comment how about expanded playoffs I
haven't heard any of the coaches
complain about that
no because hey you get to the playoffs
no you won't hear me complain about that
either I think that's exciting I think
the fans would want that get in the
tournament that's what we all talk about
getting the tournament get a chance to
win a championship overall your
expectations for this season I know it's
so early and there's so much it needs to
be done and they ultimate appearance of
the team and the composition team's
gonna be so different it is now but
going into this year what what are you
hoping for year three for Frank Reich
and the Colts well we talked about it we
talked about two primary things yeah we
talked about goals and you know number
one goal always like every other head
coach that you would have right here is
gonna say hey we got to win our division
we're in a very you know the AFC South
is now a very strong division so we're
very competitive in that division we
need to win our division that would be
goal number one but as far as
expectations really what we talk about
is the expectations of the process the
locker room the culture right we think
if we get those things right the wins
will come you know in Jacksonville Nick
Foles is there Super Bowl 50 to MVP you
know that very well
how surprised were you that it maybe
didn't click for him the way that people
thought it would his first year with the
team I was surprised I mean obviously
you know I you know I think the world of
Nick with the experience we had together
I think he's a unique player it's had an
unbelievable career so yeah I was
shocked I was shocked I mean hats off to
Gardner Minshew he did a really good job
and his exciting young player and the
whole minshew mania was was fun for the
league and and good for Jacksonville but
Nick Foles is a proven commodity I'm
sure he's not done yet
and the thing about Nick that I really
respect if they decide to go with
Gardner Minshew this year Nick Foles
will not complain privately publicly
anywhere he'll accept his role and he'll
do everything he can to make Gardner
Minshew the best quarterback he can
while also being ready to come in and do
what needs to be done if Gardner Minshew
gets injured or isn't effective and Nick
needs to play and I mean that you know
it's got it I mean you've been there and
you've done that as a player that's got
to be so hard to do you got to be able
to just not just check your ego at the
door you got to rip it out of your body
and throw it away to do that role the
way that Nick doesn't there's no doubt
but I also think that's the secret sauce
stand you know - Nick falls in and why
he is so great in those big moments
because he's not tied in he's he's not
being ripped apart on the inside like
everybody else's I mean he there's
something unique about him as a
competitor believe me I saw from the
inside out now this guy is a fierce
competitor but he just handles it
slightly different well there's
something unique about Frank Reich is a
head coach it's fun to watch your team's
play it's great to see what you've done
and it was inspiring to see you work
through so much adversity last year I
know the season didn't end the way you
wanted it to but I think there's plenty
of positive to draw from it we look
forward to seeing what happens for you
in 2020 areas Frank Reich head coach of
the Indianapolis
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports